this is Startalk computers are so
reliable and there's so much part of our
everyday life now we take them for
granted but somebody is innocently
literally or in a sense shoveling the
coal what happens if you unplug the
super computer intelligence thing it
will uh find a new source of energy no
no no no no cuz but it has its own
nuclear reactor the failure of that
logic is the assumption that it would
let you unplug it right
okay but how did it create that thing to
keep it from I'm just saying I don't I
don't um you know I'm with you here
seems like a solvable problem
so I'm looking here we have three three
levels of intelligent arrow intelligence
so it's computer doing one thing better
than anything is not getting anybody's
way a calculator calculate let it do it
one wins a jeopardy and no no that be
artificial general intelligence which
would be general intelligence but it's
not it's not hell-bent on taking over
the world
this is that IBM computer right yeah
yeah yeah yeah it goes across the yeah
yeah which one was that Watson Watson
well it's Watson okay watch this was the
super intelligence that scares him and
again I can't agree with you bill you
could at some point just unplug the dude
and and well I just think about the
Colossus project Forbin the Colossus
project mm-hmm and so this is where
these the two superpowers on earth have
nuclear arsenals that you control by
computers say they connect the two
computers trouble ensues and so you try
to unplug it but they have their own
nuclear reactors that run them these are
the movie wargames like all over it yeah
yeah yeah what was before wargames yeah
yeah and so and then a movie but the
deal is that running a nuclear power
plant is not straightforward
it takes some somebody shovelling to
coal or rate leaving stuff around in the
wastes in the pile but there's also much
much ado about the singularity rakers
walls you know I got to get him on
Startalk cuz I don't I'm just not with
him on this well I don't want to
bad-mouth him unless he's sitting him
from everybody but I didn't badmouth me
back has this happened to you Neal when
I do a college talk somebody
ask me about the singular I know and
people all computer is as smart as a
human right then this would be always
plugged in and has no arms or legs Brian
does something right right somehow what
is it gonna chase you down the street
like what's it gonna do
well no it's going to actually get the
machines to do its bidding for yes it's
like in Terminator like you said right
now with all your thermostat and your
self-driving car I'm cool with that but
this notion that somehow the world is
fundamentally different before and after
the single historical standpoint I could
buy it well I don't know will be
different but we're not gonna be it's
not we're gonna be running out of the
screaming out of the out of the
apartment know when machines took over
our physical labor do we say oh my gosh
this is the crazy day no no it happened
slowly and we're fine right now we got
people repairing machines you know so
and there's still artisans carving the
thing we gotta hit him on the show I
want to get him on the show and then
we'll give a peace of mind but we can't
leave people freaked out over the fate
of the machines that we create and their
capacity to turn us into domesticated
pets this is Startalk